[Music]
so one of the things I wrestle with as a
silver financial firm is how do we
sustain the level of growth that were
having as a company were just two years
ago we're doing 500 policies a month
then we go to a thousand policies a
month now we're doing 3,300 policies in
a month how do I sustain this and still
maintain a good level of customer
service and customer experience for
everybody this is my challenge I'm by
the way I'm greedy I want both
I want a massive explosive growth and I
want the best customer service
experience on this side can you really
pull this off so what I do to get better
in these areas I have to constantly be
in a learning mode so the title this
video says what why do we pay $60 for
$10 steak think about these restaurants
and tell me if you've ever heard any of
these restaurants or you've been to one
of these restaurants you ever been to
maestro's you've been to STK
Fleming's 610 Magnolia in Kentucky I
don't know a lobby throw lot of Columbia
sparks out of New York or your sushi out
of Boston I can give you a lot of them
Ruth's Chris have you been to these
restaurants what do they have in common
they're high-end restaurants you could
go and spend $100 per person you could
go and spend $300 for a couple just
outgoing a dinner just the other night
we went to Eddie V's and we spent $300
for two people you can go to you know
the Alexander steakhouse in San
Francisco and spend $600 for two people
why do we pay for that right and then on
the complete opposite side you got
cheesecake fat you've got Applebee's you
got Chili's why do these places charge
so much less than the other ones the
steak is the same steak I mean two
quality of steaks only gonna be a $10
difference so if it's $10 one place $20
why are they selling you for $60 $70 and
we're willing to pay for it
look there's eight things that these
guys do very well that I believe the
volume restaurants can also get better
at if they trained and paid attention on
this specific area some do a good job
but most of them don't do a good job in
this area so let me explain to what I
mean by these eight areas by the way if
you have any questions thoughts comments
about what I'm covering today comment on
the bottom and if you haven't yet
subscribe to this channel click on a sub
sub button to subscribe to the channel
as well so let me get right into it
number one the first thing they do is
they pay it
into details a big part of customer
service and experience is paying
attention to detail so what do I mean by
this if you go to a high-end restaurant
you'll typically have the hostess ask
the following question they say oh it's
great to see here Bob and Mary or I can
see you have a reservation tonight are
you here for a special event is this a
special evening here for you yes we're
celebrating life yes it's our
anniversary yes as this they grab a card
and they make a note anniversary
birthday okay whatever it is and they
write it on the note that note is given
to the waiter the waiter gets the card
that they put the order and they see
anniversary they do their special treat
for you because it's anniversary they do
special treat for it because it's
birthday on the computer they put a note
that it's your birthday and it's a
reminders every year because of their
CRM this family is back it's their
birthday it's their anniversary they
don't even ask you about it because
they're already seen in the system right
I go to a restaurant here on a regular
basis it's called neighborhood services
right we go to this place neighborhood
services and I probably go there twice a
week it's close to the office and the
service is phenomenal they know what I
order two things I ordered they don't
both my drinks they know the kind of
oysters I like I don't like the mall
pecs that they bring I like different
kind of oysters they know what kind of
oysters I like they know which salad I
order and they know the hake fish that I
like and the way to make they know it
there you know what I like they know
where I sit they know where I like to
sit all of that stuff is paying
attention to details I can pay 1/3 of
the ticket I paid there if I go to your
house and they're 50 yards apart from
each other but I go to neighborhood
services because they pay attention to
details that is an area you can also do
within your business number two the
second thing they do a service they make
you feel special by the way it doesn't
take a lot to do this making somebody
feel special is the words you use
neighborhood services says sir how are
you sir how are you Patrick so it's
either sir or your first name you can go
to yard house what's up man hey what's
happening bro hey what's it's different
it's like dude don't don't call me
what's up bro you don't know who you're
sitting with hey sir how are you sir hey
Patrick it's good to have you back
this doesn't mean all yard houses are
like this some of them are have great
managers that teach this but not all of
them
right so service they make you feel
special and by the way no matter what
you do within your business you know
some people say well you know McDonald's
is bigger than everybody else and they
don't make you feel special yeah but you
know if you look at what's the chicken
company chick-fil-a have you ever heard
the way they do customer service sir
you know pardon me all these things they
have a certain language that they use
you feel a little bit better service
with chick-fil-a you can still do that
part okay so that's the second thing is
they make you feel special number three
there's an experience what is the
experience whether it's the music it's
the smell you know it's the way they
smile they talk they walk they feel good
they have swagger you know the way they
make you feel the whole thing is a
certain experience that you get when you
go to this place fourth one is a unique
recipe that they have for instance
there's certain things they've done
that's different than other restaurants
so they'll say you know the way we make
our steak here is this thing has been
marinated for the last this many days
and this many hours and it's been
sitting here for this and we did this
with this part there's a unique story to
it right and you buy into the story so
they know how to sell the story behind a
steak you know we went to Fleming's this
past week and the guy says and this this
steak here today that we have it's a
special chef now you know when our last
chef left this is what he's telling me
our last chef left I was concerned
because we did not know what we're gonna
do he was with the company for 15 years
so when his wife got a promotion to go
to Hawaii he moved with her and he told
us and we were heartbroken and we got
this new chef and this new chef that we
got is a Japanese chef and so today's
special is a yellowtail with Japanese
whiskey such a Japanese whiskey yellow
tea and all this other stuff I said cool
all right so we tried that the
yellowtail let me tell you heavenly the
whiskey I'm not even a whiskey guy
it tastes a like rotten apple juice but
it tastes a good I like that whiskey and
it says we have this other special that
we have with the tuna that I thought and
he brought this tuna with the sauce and
they're not just the whole lemon thing
additional sauce on top of with the
lettuce on the side they can pick it I
just want to happen right now it was so
delicious so he says this is also with
the new chef it's a new unique thing
that they have and they sell you the
story right so you sell the story or
company you sell the story of smaller
the things you do with your company you
can do that you don't have to be the
biggest one to tell the story sell the
story get excited
about it you don't have to be here
necessarily with the high-end product to
get that you can do that no matter how
big your company is next special formula
you know when you go to crustaceans and
you eat at crustaceans you will see the
on family okay the on family has a
special recipe in the back that only the
on family can go into this kitchen they
have two kitchens one is for every
worker that works there the other one is
for the on family to go into that
kitchen because their recipe nobody else
can help they makes this certain garlic
noodles that if you've never had it's
absolutely addicting it's as if they put
a drug in this garlic noodles at
crustaceans that you want to overdose on
it on a daily basis so they have a
special recipe that brings you back
that's the quality part you can have a
special recipe within your company you
can have a special thing you do for
people that nobody else's experiences
you can have a special thing you do all
the time you know I went to a restaurant
the first customer you say have you ever
been here before
I have not perfect great to know that
entire not everybody got a dessert and
this was their saying listen just for
you as the first timer here we wanted to
treat you to our three special desserts
that we only make in-house I said Wow
how cool is that and they brought it you
can try this you can try this too it's
on us you're here for the first time we
really appreciate you coming up I said
wow you made me feel special I went back
over and over again because they made me
feel special with the unique things that
they had in place next one is
environment the environment is different
then it's the team that they have in
place a lot of times you'll see the
teamwork that they have you can have a
great team together when the team meshes
together everybody feels it the
customers feel it I feel it when they
don't I also feel it you know I go to a
restaurant local here Cheesecake Factory
and every time I go there it's as if
every single time we order something
from 20 times last 20 times I'll go
there on Sundays I take my kids my son
order a cheeseburger every time they
forget the cheese every time we ask for
ranch they forget the ranch we have to
ask a second time so now when I go there
guess what I say say listen John here's
a tip if you get every single order
right the first time I want to pay 18%
I'm a tippy 35 percent oh really yes but
you got to get it right the first time I
don't want to ask you twice no problem
because I want good service so for me
good service I'm willing to pay more
because that's what we have going on on
Sunday after church that we take the
kids
right and last but not least is quality
the product you know whatever you do
whatever you sell its its it benefits
you if you have a good product with high
quality some of these guys use high
quality products you may not have the
highest quality product but there's ways
on things you can do to make your
quality better so think about it this
way let me explain it to in a different
way I get people that tell me Pat how do
I get paid two hundred bucks an hour how
do I get paid a hundred bucks an hour
how are some of these guys getting paid
four hundred bucks an hour well how does
an attorney get paid 800 bucks an hour
over the other attorney that makes 200
bucks an hour he offers a better quality
product and it's him he offers a better
quality service and it's the attorney he
offers a better quality you know
advantage over the other attorneys so
you want to pay for it why can't you do
it you could do that you could improve
and by the way at the end of the day
remember what the product is you are the
product if you improve your product
everybody around you within the
companies automatically having to
improve so anyways I can't get into more
on what I'm telling you at restaurants
but all I want you to do in the next
month is go to a few different
restaurants high-end regular and take
notes and see if they remember details
see if they ask you specific questions
say honey did you see they asked that
question that said on value team and Pat
said on the video hey did you see what
just happened your take notes but did
you see that car there they pay
attention to details hey did you see
what they did with this ear and start
applying those same concepts and by the
way make notes as well when you go to a
restaurant you don't feel good because
you told the guy twice you told them
coke they brought you dr. pepper which
is the most disgusting
shell shock and experience your brain
can go through special if you cannot
stand dr. pepper somebody brings you dr.
pepper you are confused it's like
changing your religion when you drink
dr. pepper and you were thinking this is
Diet Coke and you don't want to go back
anymore so anyways I don't want to go on
a rant but all I'm telling you is the
more you pay attention to the customer
service and experience side and still
grow this I believe you can be greedy
and you can have both and grow your
company at paces by offering this side
and this side to the customer and all of
a sudden you look back and say wait a
minute we have one of the best
propositions we offer in the marketplace
maybe that's the reason why we're
started growing ways we've never
experienced before so again you got any
questions comments thoughts about what I
covered comment on the bottom
and if you haven't subscribed yet click
on the subscribe button and we do have a
PDF for you on everything I covered with
you here today there's a PDF for you to
look at and score yourself on how you do
with your business and click on a link
below in the description section it'll
take you to the site subscribe to the
newsletter you'll be given a PDF take it
out score yourself and improve in the
areas you're not good at take everybody